I'm not gonna lose her again
it's not Clark my name is Cara I will
help you
interesting groups want some help
I love this incarnation of the character
because she's so different from any that
we've seen in live action before so what
was the most unexpected place that you
found inspiration for how you would
portray her how you would craft her
personality I always say that I felt
like this character was some was was
written in the stars for me to play and
it was just wild because a lot of like
her feelings I had experienced in my
life and I think that that's a wild
thing to discover right that like to
really trust the universe because
um even if you're having bad days
um the universe really knows what it's
doing and it's guiding you and when I
got this job and and when I had to feel
all her feelings I have them I had a
little um pocket of like you know what
that feels like you know what isolation
feels like you know you know what grief
feels like you you know what protecting
someone feels like that's that's a
really beautiful thing I I think she's
such a beautiful
um superhero and I'm just so honored to
to love her and become her I I heard did
you meet up with Henry Cavill too and
did he give you some advice on on planet
so I I guess they like mixed this up
yesterday I don't know where that how it
happened but I met him after so so I met
him after
um the movie was done I gave him a big
hug it was months after and
um he had watched the film
and I have the deepest respect for Henry
Cavill um he's an icon obviously or a
Superman and uh I I you know I was like
did did did I do you well do you approve
does Superman approve does the cause
approve he's like it's Superman approved
that meant the world to me you know I'm
I'm a big
um superhero fan I've watched Man of
Steel multiple times that was just a a
kind human man like he really was like
well done and that meant the world to me
you know that's awesome you know he has
played uh Superman multiple times what
about you would you be down for for
returning in some capacity you don't
have to ask me that you don't have to
ask me that I hope so I hope I can
continue playing her and unraveling all
her beautiful
um aspects you know I feel like this
movie is a Runway to her and and to
discovering her and discovering her
Beauties and her complexities you know
we discover a lot of her pain and her
grief but but she's also a lot she's
she's Joy and uh she's she's she's just
so I I really love her I really think
she's
the world has to see more of her for
sure so you're saying you could travel
back in time
okay Bruce I can fix things I can save
people I could save my mom I could save
your parents
foreign
two of you were in an intriguing
situation while you were making this
film because James Gunn and Peter
saffron took over DC Studios announced a
new era did you have any conversations
with James and Peter about uh how to
contextualize where this film sits in
terms of the larger narrative that's
unfolding when James and Peter uh came
in the movie was uh was finished but you
know I think the the idea of Multiverse
really really uh allows you know it's
more about beginnings and endings it's a
it's a movie that allows many many
things to happen we certainly hope that
this that the the universe absorbs this
this movie and really takes advantage of
the things that this movie presents to
uh to create new
new adventures we're very fortunate that
um James and Peter loved a movie since
the minute they saw it so I you know I I
think that it is very much in their in
their hearts to you know incorporate it
in in the plan well let me ask you this
one because I mean your Batman stuff in
this film is fantastic and I want to get
into that both Ben and Michael amazing
you know would you guys be down for
sticking around in DC uh and maybe
taking on another project for James and
Peter there is a Batman and Robin film
that's on the schedule uh but I'm just
curious whether or not you'd you'd stick
around of course we would love to we can
speak about about those things yet but
uh yeah it feels like a very exciting
we're part of a family for sure that's
that's great to hear you know speaking
of uh the Batman stuff and and Michael
Keaton is the Batman that I grew up with
he's my Batman
um you know in terms of getting Michael
Keaton into this film did he have any
specific requests did he say yeah I'll
play Batman for you but you know X Y or
Z has to happen uh he didn't he didn't
have to from from the beginning I was
very very clear about my intention to to
open the conversation to his to his
thoughts and ideas and uh and we did and
we did talk a lot and and mainly the
main focus on of that conversation is
how do we find Bruce Wayne 30 years
after the last time without the audience
all saw him so that was the matter of
the most of the conversations and we
finally agreed on what it is I really
wanted
um uh Bruce Wayne that uh that goes
against the expectations of the audience
we in my opinion it wouldn't he
shouldn't be uh the the same way that we
that we saw him for the last time and
and also I needed for me it was very
important to
to provide uh possibility for
transformation during our movie and
that's why we you know I advocated and
and finally agreed with with Michael
that we should find uh Bruce the way we
find it was it always Michael Keaton and
Ben Affleck uh as your Batman you know
there were other a lot of other guys
that played Batman over the years did
you ever try to slide anybody else in
there the idea of of Batman as such an
integral part of this story is something
that started growing up and becoming
stronger and stronger as we worked uh
with Christina Hudson uh on the on the
story uh I think I think Batman became
stronger as an idea uh and also the idea
of also portraying Affleck's Batman as a
strong uh companion as a strong Ally and
father figure of of Barry at the
beginning of the movie
just to you know set up things and then
subvert them with with the operation of
the of the other Batman but Keaton was
as so we we could
have made
so universities around his Batman yeah
without a doubt you know I think the
opening sequence of this film is one of
the best that we've ever seen in a comic
book movie between the Ben Affleck
Batman Chase and then the flash rescuing
those babies from the hospital it's just
amazing could you just kind of set up
like what inspired that sequence and
maybe break it down a little bit well
yeah I went in I really wanted to make
an opening that that just capture the
the attention of the audience you you
have to really take advantage of your
opening scene to especially now with
people like with the audiences being
hard to capture their attention and uh
and I really wanted to not only you know
from an audience perspective but I
really wanted to put uh flash to a test
in the sense of yeah you can be the
fastest man alive but still there will
be something that will put you to a test
and if you have to say four babies of
being burned even though you're the
person in my life you will have to use
your width to solve those problems and
that's the way to do it you know it's
like uh it's a balancing act and and we
see in that scene we see that flash that
Barry is not just
a fast guy he's just smart to you know
to use it you usually utilize that that
speed in uh under duress and of course
you know it was uh you know I I really
wanted to to make this a big a big a big
scene and the original script there was
a scene in a volcano so I brought it up
to Christina Hudson and she loved the
idea of having babies in the air and uh
I'm very having to save them so we we
just worked on it and and and and and
kind of through the sink at it now I'm
very happy